our foreign affairs editor Debra Haines
now reports some warning this story
contains flash photography trying to
catch a glimpse of the world's most
famous white-collar fugitive former
Nissen boss carlos goon is hiding out at
this house in beirut with his wife after
skipping bail in tokyo it apparently
belongs to a company owned by his former
employer this man says he's missins
lawyer in Lebanon and he seems to want
the goons to leave the property they are
inside but we will wait for the decision
of the judge very soon lebanon received
an Interpol request to arrest mr. goon
who faces charges in japan of alleged
financial crimes so far Totti heavy he
and Nashua the general prosecution will
not stay idle with this red notice as
Perez legal prerogatives and specialties
I suppose the general prosecution will
fully implement the notice and that
includes summoning him and listening to
his testimony across the world
prosecutors in Tokyo searched mr. Gowens
house for clues to his escape his every
move should have been monitored and yet
the 65 year old with Lebanese French and
Brazilian citizenship managed to travel
from Japan via this airport in Istanbul
to Lebanon his wife's dismissed claims
he was smuggled out inside a musical
instrument case he said in a statement
that she played no part I alone arranged
for my departure my family had no role
whatsoever adding to the mystery seven
people including four pilots are being
questioned at this Turkish police
station they were arrested as part of an
investigation into mr. Gowens transit
France too will be tracking his
movements mr. GaN was instrumental in an
alliance between Nissan and French
carmaker Renault which he also once led
this Minister suggested her country
could be a safe haven new NICs had you
if mr. Gowan came to France we would not
extradite mr. Cohen because France never
extradite city citizens
he could well be safe in Lebanon too
because it doesn't have an extradition
treaty with Japan mr. Gowan is expected
to break cover next week and face the
cameras but can the man want credited
with turning around miss Anne's fortunes
do the same with his own Deborah Haines
Sky News